messieurs les jurats voulez vous
déclarez que vous entendez honorer votre
autre d'autres jours en l'invitant à
prendre place dans votre grand conseil à
partager nos expériences nos joies et
nos peines nous le voulons
messieurs les jurés vivre 7ème aignan n
dommage pour les autres grands maîtres
des vins par des producteurs acteurs et
à l'orateur prospal et de chercher la
cassette audio en semaine de 10 places
pour y annoncer ni lui ni ses titres
dans chaque huile
il s'amuse à parodier un genre le
western le thriller la sacristie et
maintenant ils sont servis sion a besoin
vos peut-il y avoir une période du film
space pons puisqu'on est en plein milieu
du tournage c'est une bonne question
mais il existe un nouveau procédé de
distribution ou vidéo c'est vrai oui
c'est là qu'à sept minutes
elles sont en vente avant que le film ne
soit terminée non mais voilà je les
trouvais bravo caporal charge est là
dans une note
la voix lui
qui parfois m'en sers dans un navette
spatiale c'est peut-être pour cela qu'il
est venu respirer dans les vignobles
mais c'est aussi et d'un certain n'est
ce pas là ce passe les films de l'espace
et de maintenant et j'ai comme ça comme
de ses murs le réalisateur de la guerre
des mots me josh lucas ces médias ne
sais pas ce que je sais le brésilien
trop occupé pour savoir que juridique
entre new world travail travail ok il
faut que je parle vrai à l'offre
charlie-chaplin haïti car c'est goodbye
charlie chaplin